[Music]
all right joining us now America's mayor
and president Trump's attorney Rudy
Giuliani how are you sir good to see by
the way I really hate that you have that
ring that is the Yankees championship
World Series ring why do you hate it I
wish I want one well you weren't the
mayor of New York City when they won I'm
one for I was there for the last one
with Mariano I should emphasize I paid
for okay no it's funny cuz remember
David Dinkins got in trouble for being
at that particular game the last game
when the Yankees world's where I was
that thinking I bought my tickets on
StubHub yeah he got him for free
you always did always either from
Steinbrenner that I treasure he said the
only politician to pay for his tickets
there you have to long story all right
let's stay on business there's no
there's no second meeting here it's
highly unlikely I always have to leave
the option open as a lawyer in case they
come across with something that really
startled us or fills some of the things
that we feel are important had a long
talk with John down today I believe
we're coming toward the end so I'm
talking to some of people who are
involved the original part of the
investigation I thank John for all of
the cooperation he gave them because he
puts us in a position where we don't
have to cooperate we gave them 1.4
million documents 32 witnesses President
Trump has answered every question and
now they're looking at his tweets to
investigate him for trying to influence
instructions just by tweet yeah I
prosecuted obstruction of justice if
they're gonna do obstruction of justice
by tweet to impeach the president
god bless us you said maybe you would
let him answer a few limited questions
on collusion but no I don't want to give
them the false impression that given
some of the revelations in the last
three or four weeks we've been driven
further away from the idea of answering
any questions from them we don't think
they have a legitimate investigation do
you think they will subpoena you was
there going to be a constitutional fight
well then the constitutional fight I
mean I think we win it one of the main
ingredients of routine ever but I was
here when you were mayor you're not
exactly shy when it comes to fight oh
and we beat Clinton in the Supreme Court
when I was mayor and I won my own case
in the Supreme Court when I argued it
and I have one of the best supreme court
lawyers United States with me you know
I'm Jay Sekulow yeah 39 cases in the
Supreme Court percent of US you
unanimously no but in any event that's
not to boast it's to say we got the
better part of the argument you have
they have presidential privilege they
can't be in can't be subpoenaed you have
the fact that even if he can be
subpoenaed that coming up some narrow
you have to show particular eyes need
and if John Dowd memo of
four months ago shows they have no
particular eyes need they have
everything let's take let's take an
example mr. president
why'd you fire Comey he's somebody
explain it over and over and over again
hey hey guys
you either believe it or you don't
believe it but don't think we're suckers
and again you put that under oath and
you're gonna chairman with perjury
trucks you believe a liar like call me
or one of the other ladies they are very
good friends and Robert Muller was
denied but the day before he got the
special counsel Johnny call me call me
is more discredited than than anyone in
this investigation
it cannot be believed so if you're
telling me you're gonna believe commis
word against the president then I know
you're trying to trap him into perjury
do you think they what happens if like
for example what happens if Muller
decides he wants to take this all the
way and subpoena the President of the
United States well we go to the Supreme
Court and we find out if you can never
been decided the only subpoena to a
president has ever happened in the in
the many years of our republic is to
bill clinton it was withdrawn it's never
been decided so we will have a case of
what they call a first impression and
will and we will find out but then we
have cases of lesser officials that were
subpoenaed and documents that was
subpoenaed from them like the SP case
and you always have to show particular
eyes to need if you have to show
particularly eyes need for a commerce
secretary of labor secretary you sure ii
saw her for a president tell me the
particular eyes need they're gonna lose
on that as i said they're gonna say we
want to hear what he said about Flint
well he said about Flint I never had
that conversation Comey said he didn't
up the conversation so why you calling
me the grand jury for that because he I
want to wrap them with a perjury charge
when you couldn't bring a regular charge
against him and the president
interesting he had wanted a tossus to it
but Martha Stewart did nothing
get her on any crying well yeah this is
Martha Stewart who did Martha Stewart
Jim call me scary it's scary if you
can't get him on the crime you gotta get
him on let's say let's get let's get him
doesn't matter how serious the crimes
what Muller sticky but I have been let's
get a celebrity wig cool what about the
SDN why this is one you work there you
have the STI why they're good they're
really good at what they do
yeah I have no I have no objections for
them what about why are they bringing in
the CFO of the Trump Organization a
thousand reasons I I've been through and
our lawyers have been through including
our Washington lawyers and our New York
lawyers we have been through every one
of the documents they've given us and
they've you know every document relating
to President Trump he is whistle clean
in that investigation that's why we
quickly waive the privilege and the
minute
Conan leaves that first conversation
between Cohan and the president where he
secretly recorded the president and lied
to him and and and pretty much drove
himself out of the bar I mean the legal
bar we put it out the minute he said he
he started putting our stuff about that
Cuomo tape where he went with his
horrible subterfuge of hiding his his a
tape recorder or all these be made
public although although he made public
eventually they eventually will what
about the Muellers and they all and I
wish they were made public tonight what
about the Muller team Andrew Weissman
who was excoriated by judges Roy holding
my wife's man have you been a longtime
prosecutor the judge Department Andrew
Weissman would be regarded by many
defense lawyers and prosecutors as a
disgrace to the he has had cases
reversed
he's been extreme court he's done
something this might shock a strange
thing but he he's withheld exculpatory
evidence you know what that means he's
got evidence that I'm innocent and he
keeps it that job and he sends an
innocent man to jail for for Merrill
executives went to jail for years and
that was a banana jail that's a
nightmare you have as a prosecutor and
was built into me by Bob Morgenthau when
I first became and then by
you know to see more yeah we've got a
lot of guilty people to prosecute dammit
you don't prosecute an innocent one and
when it's close to the line
give him the benefit out Silvio Malo who
taught me this used to say to me hey
Sylvia was in New York New York guy said
hey you know something if you let him go
no big problem they'll be back again
what about how does Jeanne Ray work for
the Clinton Foundation get on that team
how did how did the guy who gave 36 ran
to the Democratic Party you know the
team how did how did I don't know why
would not of the guy who was crying at
Hillary's because he said I'm gonna give
him the benefit of the doubt he's so
damn arrogant he doesn't care about
appearances all of us have to be do you
realize if a Republican did that what
the New York Times would have done if I
had been made special prosecutor for
Hillary Clinton and I hired Ken Starr
mr. Merrick I really do like the right
I'm glad you had to pay for it though
thank you that would have been a
controversy and the three others